ho comprato una macchina l'ho presa con
le caratteristiche che volevo io non mi
cagate u cazz
[ __ ] vada siamo arrivati Che cos'è che
esattamente non avete capito delle
parole non scartavetratemi la mmm di
come ho preso la macchina come potete
vedere sono vestito esattamente come la
Reaction che ho fatto a murry perché
sono a casa da quel giorno perché ho
l'influenza quindi altro che influencer
come scrive Ciccio non mi sono cambiato
non mi rompete le palle su come mi sono
vestito ma perché qua dobbiamo fare le
premesse che tanto non servono Comunque
questi influencer originalità Zero
riesce una famiglia a parte il fatto che
adesso si sta parlando di Mustang da
quando ho comprato la Mustang e tutti
iniziano a fare la Mustang e di qua di
là oh io l'ho guidata in America mi
piaceva l'ho comprata fine prendete una
tisana tutti quelle ne so io a me piace
una Mac li posso comprare una macchina
che mi piace santo di di poi commentando
Tra l'altro il titolo Cioè a me non mi
piace avere una macchina che hanno tante
persone quindi ho detto cacchio la massa
non ce l'ha nessuno cioè non c'era
nessuno originalità Zero allora che come
faccio ad avere una macchina originale
me la devo costruire con lo scalpello
che siamo in Minecraft più di questo che
devo fa Vabbè apriamo e vediamo Eccoci
qua non vedo l'ora eh
Lorenzo Lorenzo
asciugamano asciuga e poi poi poi
signori siamo qua su un nuovo video Mi
raccomando subito un bel pollicione in
su perché oggi
fatto Ciccio andiamo a fissare Favij
Lorenzo Cioè Scusate Avevo comprato una
macchina so che è una cosa forte ogni
tanto vado anche a far la spesa Se
volete faccio vedere anche quella eh
Cioè non è vero non l'andiamo a fissare
però
originalità 0
non lo so non lo so non so perché ho
questa foto nel mio PC è Non ho capito
ma nel senso che io ho comprato la
Mustang perché tu hai questa foto nel
tuo piscina non ho capito Aspetta non ho
capito veramente cioè giuro perché
Lorenzo Tra l'altro che saluta e mando
un abbraccio si è fatto la macchina
nuova io la voglio andare a vedere
insieme a voi Quindi subito un mega
pollicione l'ho fatto Sì l'ho già fatto
andiamo avanti Cosa c'hai da dire
Spiegami ho comprato una macchina è una
massa anche con il kit estetico Shelby
Quindi con il Shelby look se proprio
vogliamo essere precisi no inglesi io
l'ho detto in italiano E tu l'hai detto
in inglese però
Sì ma premessa io questo video in realtà
di base non volevo farlo vi dico questa
frase di solito ragazzi da quando lo
dissi Io all'epoca io non l'ho più detto
e lo stanno continuando a dire ho
copiato CiccioGamer ho copiato Ciccio Se
pensate che ho copiato CiccioGamer
lasciate un mi piace al video no che
anche lui l'ha detto all'inizio il video
o ricopiato cicciogames lui l'ha provata
in America
Ho capito che devo mettere mi piace
Madonna Mo te lo tolgo anche un'altra
persona con zero originalità che è un
pessimo canale di YouTube non sa
cucinare la carbonara si vorrebbe fare
la Mustang Ma no Ma no non credo che se
la farà mai ma no ma no Midi socio
Questa è la macchina di more
Aspetta Aspetta Aspetta fatemi tornare
indietro allora vai Santo piripillo
Quanto è bella questa
fottutissima
forse devo rivalutare un attimo tutto
quello che ho detto è una cosa
straordinaria secondo me il colore nero
un po' soffoca quelle che sono le curve
della macchina stessa però questa ci può
stare Mamma mia
bella Allora io ho visto anche la
Reaction di di di di GiampyTek E murry
allora uno che poi ve ne frega che fa
vince' l'ha fatta al benzinaio
Qua abbiamo sbagliato Siamo dalla stessa
squadra a me non me ne fotteva una sega
di dove fare sto video perché tanto
Ripeto Il video non era per flexare la
macchina era per portarla poi a fare la
Reaction a mio padre mi ha i miei amici
bella mamma mia bellissimo bellissimo
Bravo bravo sennò non facciamo le views
Cioè
non stai dissando devo dire che anch'io
Lorenzo non ce lo vedo assolutamente
dentro questo ma basta Tutti mi dicono
che non ci ci vedono la madonna mo mi
compro un Wrangler okay okay okay
non ha detto niente della benzina col
guanto eh attenzione eh quella è il
punto cruciale dietro perché Lorenzo in
autostrada non hai guidato nella
macchinuccia e l'hai fatta quella
all'amico tuo perché è la gente non si
fa li cattura No scherzo la macchina
come vedete dal cosino è in targa prova
vuol dire non è che io non la posso
ancora guidare perché non ho la targa
perché quando tu importi una macchina un
casino ragazzi vabbè andiamo avanti da
un qualcosa Oh ma perché skippate tutti
quel pezzo è qua Cioè è letteralmente il
pezzo più visto letteralmente cioè
proprio il picco più alto perché lo
saltate tutti qua qua questa cioè c'è
proprio il pezzo c'è la curva più alta
di tutto il video siamo anche a vedere
Dexter la mia nuova macchina sportiva ok
questa da quello che ho capito anche
questa qua è un V6 Più che altro perché
non pagano il superbollo eccetera
eccetera Che figo che c'è il tasto Mi
piace perché ancora non ho capito se
dovevo mettere mi piace al video No
questi youtuber tutti con questa Mustang
Cioè ma vai vai partiamo col Allora hai
ancora un minuto vedo più o meno di
video vai di dissing che sennò non ci
facciamo che View facciamo Però ripeto
questi youtuber che tutti con la stessa
macchina ma veramente uno schifo uno
schifo
D'accordo
va bene Hai finito così
c'è una sentiamo una sgasata cos'è
cos'era strofinale cos'era cos'è non si
capisce e anche sfasata l'inquadratura
Santo Iddio ciccio ciccio hai sbagliato
il template il Colgo lo devi mettere qua
Vabbè mi aspettavo un po' più di
cattiveria nei miei confronti invece mi
ha fatto quasi Complimenti Grazie Ciccio
allora ragazzi Volevo chiedere scusa se
ho comprato una macchina perché non
pensavo che potesse destare tutta questo
tutto questo interesse è
se dovessi mai andare che ne so a fare
la spesa o robe del genere faccio video
a questo punto perché a quanto pare
quando compro cose interessa Volevo
chiedervi Scusa ragazzi se sto facendo
praticamente solo Reaction ai prossimi
due video saranno sempre Reaction perché
purtroppo da casa influenzato non è che
posso fare molto ma anche video fuori
casa torneranno molto presto per adesso
mi sto focusando sulle Reaction che sono
i video che mi richiedono meno tempo e
sono quelli che mi vanno di più tra
guarda sempre così Eh quando tu fai un
video e ci metti poco è quello che va di
più e la prima regola di YouTube A
quanto pare i prossimi video due
Reaction senza che si parli della mia
macchina Basta Vi prego basta parlare
della mia macchina e basta Ti prego
finiamola qua perché non se ne può più E
che cacchio ci vediamo ai prossimi video
iscrivetevi al canale Scusatemi ancora
se ho l'influenza se mi sentite la voce
un po' così E noi come sempre Ehm come
sempre ho perso il telecomando Ah eccolo
qua eh Ci vediamo al prossimo Guarda
guarda come sono conciato Guarda guarda
Sto montando i video così adesso Pensa
come sto messo Dai vabbè Eh bella
ragazzi